so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome
i'm ben lee game director hearthstone
and today we'll be taking you on an
in-depth exploration of our brand new
game mode hearthstone mercenaries but
what's this new setting all around me
welcome to the mercenary village
this will be a central home base for you
and your growing crew of mercenaries
evolving over time as you take on
bounties and battle other players
mercenaries is truly unlike any other
mode we've added tearstone before
it offers a persistent world full of
choice and progression to explore
alongside your personalized team of
azeroth legends
today we're excited to share numerous
mercenary reveals a tour of the village
and some big surprises that you won't
want to miss so whether you're a
thrill-seeking opportunist or a
benevolent bounty hunter there's always
a job and the promise of treasure for
those of you up to the challenge
thank you all for joining us and now
let's jump straight in with our official
trailer reveal for hearthstone
mercenaries
[Music]
kazakus how long have we plotted and
planned dear lady presta it's finally
our grand
opportunity
we'll need some marks to do our dirty
work
help me if you can oh i'm in trouble
bring these bounties in and i'll pay
double
you'll go from ranks to
just be smart and wear your thinking cap
now honestly but really can't be it's a
reward
[Music]
they say that fortune favors
when you've got enough gold you're
influencing people and you're winning
some credits
your glory grows
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the village everyone we
hope you enjoyed that trailer
mercenaries drops you into the rich
world of azeroth with a unique
perspective instead of being the
almighty individual hero you'll play
leader to your own mercenary enterprise
this journey will take you to the far
reaches of azeroth hunting bounties for
increasingly dangerous foes to reap the
rewards and these jobs don't only net
you nice coin the battles along the way
level up your mercenaries to unlock
abilities and allow you to find
upgradeable items now i'm sure you're
eager to venture off to take on your own
dangerous and hopefully lucrative
bounties but first let's join valeria in
her hunt for hogger and get familiar
with an entirely new system of combat in
hearthstone mercenaries you may remember
from our blizzcon line announcement that
mercenaries is hearthstone's take on an
rpg experience with roguelike mechanics
let's start by taking a look at a
mercenary in play where you'll first
notice familiar attack and health stats
what's totally different is that each
mercenary has a core set of unique
abilities which appear as actions when
selected there's tremendous variety in
how these can impact battlefield healing
buffing summoning sizzling and of course
going face
wait there is no face
that's right in mercenaries victory is
achieved by wiping out your opponent's
team that might take some getting used
to for rexon
all abilities have a speed value and
some also have a cooldown speed
determines the order of actions the
lower the number the sooner that action
will take place
cooldowns on the other hand tend to come
with the strongest abilities when a
mercenary comes into play any of their
abilities with cooldowns will be
inactive until enough turns have passed
once used the timer starts again and
you'll definitely want to be making use
of these potential game changers in each
round of combat you'll first choose your
team's moves in the command phase before
watching the battle unfold all at once
positioning timing and strategic
planning of your turn are critical in
the outcome of combat this can be tough
as the state of the board may change
considerably once the spells start
flying and that clutch meteor finisher
you were banking on won't happen if the
mercenary is falling
so you've probably also noticed the red
green and blue coloring of each
mercenary stat bars these represent if a
minion is a protector fighter or caster
respectively we call these roles and
they play a major part in the makeup of
mercenaries let's take a look with a
couple examples
meet the main tanks of mercenaries while
they aren't always the quickest
protectors love holding the front line
and taking most of the punishment so
that your squishies don't have to with
abilities that grant taunt and a cart
load of endurance to boot they'll help
your team control the flow of the fight
take a look at jaraxxus eredar lord of
the burning legion as you might notice
protectors can also dish out some
serious damage trust me you don't want
to catch these fists if he's teamed up
with demons next let's take a look at
the wielder of tusks of manorath himself
garrosh hellscream if anyone knows how
to properly armor up for a fight it's
this guy the more enemies the merrier as
garrosh's horde strength ability will
add increasing bonuses to his health
maybe think twice before you summon that
extra minion when you're looking to cut
through the competition with raw damage
and finesse fighters are the way to go
their high attack makes them key threats
on the battlefield along with abilities
that keep your team's offensive pressure
building check out warmaster voon
favored by dragons and feared by enemies
this fighter will keep your opponents
running for cover with a flurry of flame
and axes boone can also summon
additional dragons into the fight for a
quick strike that simultaneously
empowers his fire breath if up close and
personal is more your style you're going
to want a fighter like samuro in your
squad unleash a whirlwind of blade on
your foes or create deadly deception
with mirror images while the blademaster
doesn't have the highest health direct
damage is always a gambit since a
well-timed whirling blade can mitigate
future damage there's no denying that
blades and bronze contribute to a
formidable team's front line but you'll
also want to bring some backline
firepower and a good healer that's where
casters come in they keep your team in
the fight and unleash devastating spell
combos to turn the tide of battle who
better to start with than our favorite
prodigal priest andu and rit harness the
power of holy to buff and sustain your
team's health throughout the fight while
also delivering consistent damage to the
enemy team as a leader of humans and
azeroth anduin's abilities are
significantly amplified when fighting
alongside more of his kin moving on
ready your house and chat because
blinkfox is up next as another caster in
hearthstone mercenaries this crafty
canine of the arcane uses the enemy
team's abilities against them while also
refreshing and hastening friendly
cooldowns notice the arcane combo
keyword in mercenaries this means a
bonus effect if a previous arcane
ability was used by another member of
the team this term and yes there are
combos for all schools of matter we'll
be checking out examples of spell school
synergy teams later on in the show let's
cover one more central piece of the roll
system in mercenaries there's a
relationship of strengths and weaknesses
to consider when building teams and
choosing engagements
protectors deal double damage to
fighters fighters deal double damage to
casters casters deal double damage to
protectors that two times damage
multiplier applies to both attacks and
abilities but only on offense
opportunities to target these weaknesses
and deal critical damage are
contextually highlighted on the game
board and when planning bounties you'll
be able to discover some information to
use this system to your favor most of
the time it's best to have a team that
can confidently take on a range of roles
in the battlefield capitalizing on the
weaknesses of your opponent's roles
while being mindful of your own is a
critical piece of tactical decisions
i hope you enjoyed a first look at a
handful of mercenaries there's so much
more to explore how stats and abilities
rank up as you level treasures you
discover in bounties that modify and
amplify abilities and even unique
equipment for each mercenary that
bolsters their kit in variety of ways
we'll be unveiling all of that today so
stick around
now let's check back in with faciba at
the campfire
[Music]
thanks joe and a warm and cozy welcome
from the campfire to all of you
let's start the tour here at the center
piece of your mercenary village where
visitors can stop by for a little r r
during their stay these campfire guests
often have tasks you can pursue for
special rewards but the question of who
will come to your village and when is
mostly up to chance
in game visitors will appear around your
campfire as seen here clicking on the
campfire presents you with the task
board where you can see the objectives
along with rewards for completion this
is pretty similar to hearthstone's quest
system just remember to come back to the
task board after you've fulfilled the
requirements to collect your reward
speaking of task rewards let's talk
about equipment which is often a major
reason you'll want to complete a
specific visitor's job one of the core
ways in which you'll define a
mercenary's play style is through their
equipment only one piece can be active
at a time with three unique options to
collect and upgrade let's take a look at
what illidan is able to acquire razer
fist will provide a straightforward
damage bonus to his winged assault
ability we all know illidan loves to
attack and this defensive option will
prove useful if your team is lacking in
the heels department i'm sure you can
already imagine what's coming next of
course you'll make for one very happy
betrayer if you can acquire and equip
the war glaives of asinoth with war
glaves in hand outcast attack becomes a
massive threat to the enemy's flanks
moving on let's introduce karen
bloodhoof
as you'll see his equipment options
present a significant strategic decision
reincarnation pairs great with this
tanking torrent and may even foil your
opponent's command phase game plan swift
totem will amp up the bonus from
endurance aura allowing your team to
unleash big abilities well ahead of your
enemy's actions thunderous sash on the
other hand can make karen's war stomp a
frustrating hindrance to enemy teams
that rely on getting in early attacks
and buffs making sure your mercenaries
are well equipped is always going to
give you an edge in combat so be sure to
keep an eye on those visitors and
complete their tasks to gear up
and uh hello again ben cheers
you know sitting around a nighttime
campfire before going into battle it
almost reminds me ben i think
something's wrong with the portal
ah of course diablo today we're thrilled
to announce that hearthstone will be
welcoming and fully embracing a carriage
from a different blizzard universe
initially playable as a mercenary is now
our pleasure to introduce you to the
arch rival of the nephilim
[Music]
i will feast upon this world
you now speak to the lord of terror
there is no escape
[Music]
trample before me
the lord of terror will go live at the
launch of mercenaries and can be found
in mercenaries packs he'll also be
available in the diamond diablo
pre-purchase bundle starting today
we hope you're as excited as we are to
bring a little terror to the tavern
wait
you're bringing what to my tavern
oh hey again everyone now of course any
good village needs an upstanding tavern
and this will play an important role in
your mercenaries journey let's take a
look in-game once you build a tavern it
will function as your mercenary
collection where you can customize teams
and individual characters like the card
collection you'll be able to navigate
the full library of mercenaries each has
their own page to manage portraits
abilities and equipment we love that
mercenaries opens up a new way to tell
stories with this amazing cast of heroes
and villains that extends to the art
with representations of the characters
in different stages of their own lore we
all know arthas and his path from
beloved prince to lich king when you
first unlock a mercenary you'll have the
default portrait as shown for arthas
here each character also has two
alternates which can be earned from
mercenary packs and in some cases tasks
their portraits are a snapshot of
notable growth and notoriety to collect
and you'll find the theme consistent
throughout the roster on top of the
portraits there are also different frame
rarities from normal to golden to
diamond and each bringing more gravitas
with added animations and effects next
feast your eyes on this young and
adorable king crush he may have started
out cute as a button but once those
teeth grew in
yeah distract your enemies with extreme
cuteness or intimidate with pure terror
it's up to you as you unlock and collect
portraits you'll open up new ways to
bring the mercenary characters together
maybe you want to have illidan tyrande
and malfurion all teaming up during
simpler times in addition to customizing
cosmetics you'll come here to upgrade
abilities and equipment in mercenaries
unlocking a higher rank of an ability
significantly increases that character's
power level when a new mercenary joins
your collection at level 1 they will
have a single ability the second unlocks
at level 5 and the third unlocks when
the character reaches level 15. let's
take a look at milhouse's kit of arcane
assault to compare his ability ranks
these are typically a linear increase to
effectiveness but in the case of arcane
bolt you'll be able to ramp up the spell
damage you gain more quickly in addition
to a boost in raw damage upgrading is
done through a new in-game resource
system called mercenary coins each
character has their own coin which
you'll earn from bounties pvp and
mercenary packs
now let's shift gears to teams in the
taverns mercenary collection you'll see
a sidebar to manage teams similar to
standard card decks a team in
mercenaries is made up of six while you
can only have three in play the
remaining three will make up the bench
when one of your in-play mercenaries
falls in battle you'll bring in a member
from the bench at the end of that combat
round so far today we've taken a look at
how this huge new modes gameplay works
with several reveals of mercenaries and
their abilities equipment and art what
do you think acebo are we ready to dive
into team building absolutely
all of you have now seen the core
components that define an individual
mercenary
now the fun really starts as we start
looking at the bigger picture of
maximizing synergies you never know
exactly which mercenaries you'll
discover in the world but there are a
variety of opportunities to bring them
together in complementary ways
let's start with a few examples of the
most familiar relationships minion types
murlocs offer versatile strength on
their own and work together to overwhelm
their opponents with agile aggression
and power in numbers
[Music]
now if you're more of a land animal
person we got you covered you'll also
find plenty of azeroth's fiercest beasts
and renowned handlers
[Music]
lead a demon army into battle and
dominate your enemies with overwhelming
numbers
[Music]
that's just a few of the many minion
types to find in collecting mercenaries
and having one to two ways to combine
their strengths on the battlefield is
highly beneficial
now let's talk about an entirely
different way mercenaries can combine
their skills to make a successful team
spell schools have become an integral
part of hearthstone and we're extending
that approach to mercenaries in a major
way
while the loyalties and motivations of
certain characters may clash combining
wielders of a specific magic will unlock
incredibly powerful combos and teamwork
fire synergy can come from a traditional
fire mage to elementals to a whirlwind
of flames itself and can chain their
abilities to unleash aoe destruction
[Music]
wow that team looks pretty intense i
think we need to chill out a bit and
move on to the next spell school
[Music]
there's clearly some awesome power to be
harnessed using the elemental spell
schools but now let's look at the
tremendous support and sustain a holy
team can provide
[Music]
[Music]
now we can't show holy without its polar
opposite the suppression and control
that shadow magic lens can be deadly
with some clever play
again there are plenty more spell
schools to explore and build teams
around in mercenaries but i hope you're
all enjoying a preview to start
considering how these synergies can be
leveraged
definitely we didn't even check out
nature yet and that's got to be one of
my favorites but the show must go on
in addition to spell schools and minion
types there are other outside the box
ways to approach combat strategy let's
check out one more example that uses
tricks traps and the combo keyword to
build momentum
[Music]
remember that a team has six mercenaries
so combining two to three of these
themes amongst your roster is a pretty
good idea
all right that wraps up this stop of the
tour i'm sticking around at the tavern
where are you taking these fine viewers
next to cebu we're actually headed
towards the portal see you in a bit joe
now it's time to see how you'll access
the world and take on bounties in
mercenaries
so the portal here is what we call the
travel point
initially you'll have to make do with a
reliable darkmoon mare to get the job
done but as you upgrade the village the
technology and capability of the travel
point increases
let's head into the game to learn a
little bit more about
wait is that sarge sarge what are you
doing you're supposed to be in the
tavern
what do you mean there's not enough
cheese there's so much cheese in there
okay fine if you have to go then pick me
up a block of darnassian blow please be
careful it's dangerous out there
we're very excited to announce that
sarge will be available as a new world
warcraft mount when the game mode
launches complete the mercenaries
tutorial and start your first bounty to
automatically unlock sarge on your wow
count
interacting with the travel point is
your first step to starting a bounty
which you can think of as a pve mission
there are several zones to explore along
with progressively higher level targets
to hunt let's dive in and head to
felwood here we have the available
bounties with some information to help
you decide on the right job the target
of a bounty will be the final boss of
that run so noting their role can be
beneficial in bringing your a team of
counters hmm
i think we'll take on raven the hunter's
bounty for some good old furbolg
fighting
remembering that our target is a
protector i'm thinking this arcane
awesomeness team here will fare quite
well since it has all of our highest
level caster marks so in we go to
felwood to find raven every bounty map
is procedurally generated meaning you'll
get unique map layouts along with
randomized encounter enemies and points
of interest to navigate clicking on the
nodes gives you some details but you'll
also need to use your intuition and
decide which routes to take along the
way let's unpack some of the obstacles
and rewards for clearing them that
you'll find on your adventures minor
encounters are made up of enemies that
should be manageable given your team is
on par with that bounty's power level
keep your guard up though as losing
members on your team will restrict your
options in the long run here you'll find
not all enemies have an alignment and
they can also have keyword effects like
deathrattle always take a moment to
scope out their moves and strategize a
game plan now the exciting part
encounter victories reward experience to
all members of your party on top of that
one mercenary in your party will be
rewarded with a discovered treasure that
can bolster stats and abilities or add
an entirely new spell or attribute
treasure bonuses last throughout that
bounty run but are not permanent
upgrades to the mercenary side note as
long as one mercenary is still standing
at the end of a battle all damage on
that mercenary will be fully recovered
before the next encounter
elite encounters work the same way but
the risks and rewards are far greater
these enemies will offer a major
challenge and it's unlikely that your
party will come out unscathed then again
think of the super treasure
substantially bigger bonuses come from
besting these elites and can give you a
crucial advantage for the final battle
you'll also come across spirit healers
that simply revive any fallen members of
your party after limping away from an
elite encounter
this can be a beautiful discovery that
saves your bounty run beyond encounters
and spirit healers keep an eye out for
the many other curveball points of
interest that fill the roads to bounty
bosses take the mysterious stranger
where choosing to engage can reveal a
helpful ally confounding adversary or a
neutral surprise
or you can find and activate boons that
empower all characters of a specific
role for the rest of the bounty
including enemies alas after battling
your way through the twists and turns
you've made it to the end of the line
the final and greatest challenge will be
your bounty target occupying a special
boss room along with their hoarded
treasures
now it's time to bring out the best of
your team and maximize the value of
every treasure boon and bonus to finish
the job successfully completing the
bounty will immediately open the
treasure chest for those sweet sweet
rewards however if your team was wiped
out at any point in the run you'll only
retain the experience gains of the run
any particular bounty can be attempted
and completed an unlimited number of
times with each instance offering a new
random map with the same final boss
since you can also glean the potential
rewards by inspecting the treasure chest
of a bounty's map there's many cases
where replaying and beating the same
bounty for that certain special
mercenary loot makes sense let's come
back to the travel point menu where
you'll also see additional difficulties
a quick note that completing all of the
bounties in each zone on normal will get
your team well into the 20 to 25 level
range so what comes next once you
upgrade the travel point in your village
from a horse to a flight point sorry
horse heroic difficulty will be unlocked
bounty difficulties can be toggled at
any time in the village heroic versions
of a bounty will obviously scale up the
power level of enemies and bosses but
there's also an increase in map size and
layout that ramps up the challenge and
stakes of each run now if you're also
wondering hey aciva could you please
explain that giant portal behind you
well that's actually the tier 3 upgrade
of the travel point
at launch only normal and heroic
bounties will be available
however in an upcoming content update
we'll be opening up legendary difficulty
access by fully upgrading the travel
point of your village to the portal here
this is just one big piece of the
content that we have planned to follow
the release of mercenaries as we'll also
regularly be adding themed updates with
new bounties mercenaries and the
additions to the village
with that you're well equipped to start
tackling the wide world of bounties that
awaits outside the village
so now let's shift gears and talk about
pvp in mercenaries
in the essence of civility we like to
keep all the drama contained here in the
fighting pit
this functions as your access point to
battling other players
and now i'll let our resident pvp expert
joe fill you in on what to expect
so you've bested a few bounties and now
your party is ready to challenge other
players well step on down into the
fighting pit
i'm game designer joe killian here to
show you the ropes of pvp and
mercenaries once you've unlocked and
built a fighting pit in your own humble
village you'll be ready to get started
inside you can select from your teams
and prepare just like choosing a deck
and standard at launch a mercenary's pvp
match will consist of both players
bringing a single team of six and just
like in a bounty encounter defeating
your opponent's entire party will secure
victory one key difference from other
game modes is that you take your party
into combat as is that means the
progress you've earned in mercenary
levels ability tiers
and equipment
all play a direct role into your pvp
prowess
as you can imagine the matchmaking in
mercenaries is quite a bit more complex
than other game modes since it needs to
weigh all of these aspects to ensure
relatively even power levels while
you'll always be paired up against
opponents with teams of similar strength
we love that these factors open up a ton
of potential for unique asymmetrical
matches now let's talk strategy for a
moment
unlike pve where you can gather some
information on what you'll be up against
in pvp your team will face a mixed bag
of opponents with varying roles and
synergies you may find yourself up
against a protector-heavy orc team or
thrown into a fiery foray of elementals
and casters
i like to bring beasts and nature
casters so i have good coverage of all
the roles and some powerful synergies if
you want to come out swinging with all
fighters that choice is yours players
will earn daily rewards just for
participating in pvp
but with great ratings comes great
rewards and at increasing milestones
you'll unlock more and more mercenary
reward chests however unlike the ranked
chests from standard these contain
mercenary specific items like mercenary
packs and coins so you can continue to
expand and improve your mercenary's
roster we're incredibly excited to open
up an entirely new way to pvp in
hearthstone and now you know everything
you need to get started so it's up to
you and your party good luck in the
fighting pit and we'll see you in
mercenaries
[Music]
welcome back everyone
one of my favorite aspects in pvp and
mercenaries is that you can't see your
opponent's command phase actions which
often obscures combat ability order
adding a new layer of challenge to
tactical decisions
on the other hand watching some good
combat chaos unfold is half the fun
alright let's touch on a few other areas
of the village starting with the
merchant cart
here you'll find the mercenaries shop
with you guessed it mercenaries packs
this new kind of hearthstone pack
contains mercenaries items with the same
pack opening feel
inside you'll find coins for crafting
mercenaries or upgrading abilities and
equipment
along with actual new mercenaries and
even alternate portraits
occasionally you might find limited time
offers and deals here from the merchant
so it's good to stop by and check in
tucked in over here is the mailbox to
keep your village connected to the world
besides your mercenaries team's fan mail
of course we'll also be sending updates
on new content patch changes and other
fun stuff here so keep an eye out for
the handy exclamation mark that you have
on red mail
oh hey i think i see joe doing a bit of
combat training over there
keep it up joe
thanks asiba
that's enough training for now let me
show you the last stop on our tour where
i'll swap out swords and shields for
blueprints
this workshop here is where all the
constructing and upgrading happens
throughout the day we've explored how
different areas of the village
contribute to our overall journey in
mercenaries but at the start you'll
basically have an open plot of land as
your empty canvas and it's up to you to
decide what you want to build and
upgrade
when it comes to building up your
village everything is done with gold and
only gold the first step is to create a
starting version of each structure to
unlock its benefits for example the
fighting pit gives you access to pvp
from there some structures can be
upgraded for added benefits and bonuses
upgrading the campfire for instance
opens up more spots for visitors to come
give you tasks speaking of the campfire
let's see how the others are doing
well i don't know about you two but
after all that constructing it feels
good to be back by the campfire
you know milhouse conjured these and
supposedly arcane infusion tastes like
blueberries
oh
anyways
hey everyone at home along with what joe
talked through we have plenty more
exciting additions planned for the
village and you'll see those arrive in a
future update
be sure to keep some gold tucked away to
get your mercenaries the new digs and
with that i think we'll call this tour
rap ben
indeed you both rocked it thank you so
much to all of you who came along with
us in seeing what mercenaries is all
about
we couldn't be more excited to welcome
you into this massive new adventure
whether your goal is conquering all the
heroic bounties ascending the pvp
leaderboards or collecting a legendary
roster of renowned heroes and villains
on behalf of the team we sincerely
appreciate you continuing to support
play and communicate with us around the
hearth
we're looking forward to hearing your
thoughts on today's announcements
and we'll see you at the launch of
mercenaries on october the 12th until
next time we'll see you in the tavern
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you